I sent my kids to a violin summer camp
and sign them up first day of of summer
camp I dropped them off and every single
kid was wearing a mask and I thought
gosh that's awfully weird didn't think
of any anything of it I was I got a call
from the camp we're requiring masks
and I was completely shocked there's no
Mass mandate in the county no mask
mandate in the park that they're in we
we've been we're past masks why are you
requiring masks only for the summer camp
at this park and they said well it's to
protect the children as if my my biggest
imperative isn't to protect my children
and I came in guns blazing furious and I
pulled my kids out and they said sorry
no refund and I said oh you do not know
who you're dealing with do you and I
said I want the name of your board of
directors I want all of their contact
information and let's have a
conversation about how this bait and
switch situation happened and about how
you have no concern about the future of
children and the well-being of children
and I mean why was I the only parent
that was horrified
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today are
the authors of the new book stolen youth
how radicals are racing innocence and
indoctrinating a generation Carol
Markowitz and Bethany Mandel Carol
Bethany welcome to the Reuben report
thank you Carol this must be freaking
you out because we usually do this over
Skype or in person when we're drunk
right but here we are sober in the
middle of the day talking about stuff
hard to like not fix my hair and look at
myself you know and Bethany we've never
met before no but you're in the mix of
these uh mothers who are fighting this
lunacy I just tag along with Carol
basically how did you guys decide to
write a book together I'll go to the new
person first I'm gonna have to blend
this so I don't want to cause a cat
fight here right now
so Carol and I've been friends for a
really long time it's hard to do but
we're friends and we have very similar
World Views and she writes The Columns
that I always meant to write but didn't
get around to emailing the editor and
then I'd read it and I'm like dang she
is that better than I would have and so
we've been talking about it for years
and we had another iteration of the book
proposal get your village off my
children and then covet hit and we kind
of everything froze and we sort of said
let's let's see where the dust settles
and then the dust settled and we
realized like well get your village off
my children is legit we really need to
get them away from our children and so
we he said like you know there is this
woke stuff happening younger and younger
and but do we have enough for a book
like is there enough material here and
so we started Google doc and we just
started dumping stuff in and we realized
after a week we have too much stuff it's
the problem isn't is there a book is
like how can we only write one book
about this and how do we narrow this
down and so
um we just started plugging and um you
know we had a lot of inter I mean I
don't know how much you want to say but
do you want to you want to take over
this part of the story well let me maybe
do a little bio part first before we get
fully to that just so that people have a
frame of reference here why don't you
both say like how many kids you have
ages things like that that kind of frame
this in a yeah in a personal way yeah
so Bethany Mandel I am a columnist for
Deseret News and uh Fox News and I like
I write things places and I'm on Twitter
yeah I do the tweets yeah um and I'm an
editor of a children's book series that
is like super patriotic and wonderful
called Heroes of Liberty and I have six
kids age nine and under
I'm Carol Markowitz I'm a columnist at
the New York Post and Fox News and I
have only three kids which seems like a
lot until you meet Bethany uh as someone
with two three does yeah you gotta catch
up so you guys okay so you get this
Google dog going you're dumping stuff in
there trust me I wish I could wake up on
any given day and have no woke thing to
go crazy over so I can see how this
thing would be expanding and expanding
and then how did you decide to frame it
like sort of purely around education and
was that just from being moms and you
were like this is clearly the thing that
matters most so we have two different
paths that we have taken I have kids in
public and private schools I have two
sons in public and a daughter in private
and Bethany Home schools and so what we
were seeing was during covid
um kids were just the last priority they
just completely weren't considered they
would post reopening plans and not even
put children in them they had to live
under restrictions far longer than
anybody else and we saw that it was
really getting to be a problem where
kids were just not considered in society
at all and so our book focuses on that
but also on how schools are targeting
them and publishing companies and
libraries and
um doctors offices all of it targeting
for woke indoctrination are you shocked
at the amount of parents that just go
along with whatever crazy thing happens
next I mean I can tell you as a father
of a six month old and a four-month-old
the idea that you know is it the CDC or
the NIH now you know they want to put in
the schedule yeah the coveted
vaccination for six month olds like
there's no chance in hell right that I
like literally Over My Dead Body but but
they do things and then people just go
along with it was was that shocking to
see or is that just kind of parent 101
no no it's actually the opposite of
parent one-on-one the the parent 101 was
not what parent101 should be I mean the
way it functions what they what you're
supposed to do is lay your life on the
line and do anything possible to save
your children to help your children in
any way shape or form and what we saw
over covid I'm sorry but was a lot of
parents saying well I don't want to be
the loud mouth I don't want to be the
troublemaker and so they went along with
it one of the craziest things that
happened over covet and our book isn't
just about covert there's so so much
more to it but this sort of drove it
home for me last summer summer of 22
um right that was 22. yeah it's going
faster it really is I sent my kids to a
violin summer camp and sign them up
first day of of summer camp I dropped
them off and every single kid was
wearing a mask and I thought gosh that's
awfully weird didn't think of any
anything of it I was I got a call from
the camp we're requiring masks and I was
completely shocked there's no Mass
mandate in the county no mask mandate in
the park that they're in we we've been
we're past masks why are you requiring
masks only for the summer camp at this
park and they said well it's to protect
the children as if my my biggest
imperative isn't to protect my children
and I came in guns blazing furious and I
pulled my kids out and they said sorry
no refund and I said oh you do not know
who you're dealing with do you and I
said I want the name of your board of
directors I want all of their contact
information and let's have a
conversation about how this bait and
switch situation happened and about how
you have no concern about the future of
children and the well-being of children
and I mean why was I the only parent
that was horrified every other parent
dropped their kid off dutifully in a
mask for a music camp in the middle of
summer in a literal swamp we call do you
see the swamp for a reason it is a swamp
and every single parent would just study
you know this is and I had a lot of work
to do that week I had piled all the rest
of my work that summer including for
this book into that week and I pulled my
kids out and I said okay looks like I'm
not sleeping this week and I did Mommy
camp with them the whole week and from 7
PM until 2 A.M I worked and I don't
understand why more parents didn't take
that perspective so Carol you were I
know this factually you were dealing
with this nonsense in Brooklyn and the
crazy things they were putting your kids
through what what was the snap point for
you well the snap point was I saw that
nothing was getting better but just to
for a slight defense of parents I would
say that kovid ran into cancel culture
in such a way that parents were afraid
of having their lives destroyed if they
spoke out and if they spoke up and while
that doesn't excuse anybody they should
still be pulling their kids out of camps
and doing stuff like that it does
explain why parents didn't fight harder
at the time people did get fired for
saying this we all pick our battles like
did I mask my kids at moments that I did
not feel comfortable with right
absolutely I did
um but I that summer of 2022 really
killed me right a little bit past the
point where any of this made sense and I
think many people would argue it never
made sense that's a whole other thing
um so when you would talk to other
parents when you do this at the violin
camp or now you're talking to you know
parents at your kids schools like was it
really just fear or is it just that
people actually had no freaking clue
like they're just it in some ways
they're not adults something like that
like that's what we have a Gen X
generation of people that never fully
became adults it was a combination in
Brooklyn I had people who
just like well the CDC says
the CDC says then I do it and the
doctors say and I would be like no the
doctors don't really say but then there
were people who would tell me like I
agree with you but I can't speak up and
that was really terrifying to me um the
we opened with a chapter on the history
of totalitarian societies and how this
has happened before this you know forced
Conformity has happened before and it's
happening here now and it's really scary
to watch I know you mentioned this in
your book don't burn this country and I
which I read you know yeah really good
book
um but you know the Conformity thing and
those people feel like they have to say
exactly the right thing in the exact
right way it really scared people off
from doing the right thing for their
kids if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of mindless dribble
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell